[Music]
good morning goldie
my name is guy and i live in free city
i have everything i need
[Music]
except one thing hey
excuse me hey
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
the stuff we do day after day literally
not once
today's gonna be different goldie what
are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy
i have to tell you something there is no
easy way to say this this world it's a
video game
i really want to kiss you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
wait you let who kiss you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here
with my best friend trying to help him
get through a tough time
now if that's not real i don't know what
it is
millie i know this world is just a game
but this place these people that's all i
have
thanks guys who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy you're absolutely right who is he
or she indeed this loser is ruining the
game man
i don't care if he's arnold freaking
schwartz invader
terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
[Music]
was that cool it felt really cool we
could change
our world but we have to fight together
i don't even know what's happening right
now
but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
they seem nice
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you may very well
mean the difference between life
and death
your reputation precedes you i have to
admit i wasn't expecting an invitation
back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting
two versus what he's gotta be kidding
what the hell
[Music]
smoke in the air
[Music]
[Applause]
you have any idea what those markers are
they look pretty ancient
the tracks end here it's definitely
bravo team they don't just disappear
where the hell are we that lightning and
hit those markers and it took us
somewhere
guys so what
are we like guardians of the galaxy now
on our six
dear bros
holy [ __ ]
did you see that thing
pull back this is officially above my
pay grade
i don't care what those creatures are
we destroy them and close the gateway
i'm getting us all home
so
[Music]
from your secret friend underneath
having
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
why is he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
[Music]
you're part of this too
oh my part of it
you'll see
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband fee renovates houses
thinking about moving but you're gonna
wait until the interest rates go down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than us
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
won't win i've always found it best
not to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and come but my plan was to
drive us away
gloria plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
[Music]
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen natasha don't
slouch i'm not slouching you're going to
get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap
[Applause]
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go
[Music]
oh
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
the time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
look like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn
get used to it
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you
what radar will they will they shoot at
[Music]
[Applause]
us
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
[Music]
my flock this will not be
a war of heroes
nations will slaughter each other while
we get
rich this is going to be fun
[Applause]
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world burns
son the truth is the world is ruled
by corruption and greed we must do
something
certainly
we are the first independent
intelligence
agency refined but brutal
civilized but merciless
welcome to the club very clever it's
time
to pour fuel
on the fire of revolution
yes my shepherd
welcome englishman
rasputin your reputation precedes you
[Music]
let's end this as gentlemen after all
[Music]
why is it that boys are always so messy
good morning miss garcia good morning
sunshine
i miss you i could kiss you right now
sunday curfew is now in effect
all unauthorized citizens must stay
indoors
tensions rise as we enter the 213th week
of lockdown
grim new reality emerges 23 has mutated
beginning thermal scan thermal scan
110 all infected americans are being
forced into quarantine camps
sarah every little thing sir what's
going on
department of sanitation sarah talk to
me i think my neighbor has a fever it'll
be so much easier
if you just open the door mrs grant
you have visitors
[Music]
beginning thermal scan three two
one anomaly detected
armed guards will be arriving in four to
six hours
you must not attempt to leave your home
or you will be shot on site
i know you're in there
you're coming i have to let you go
no no no
sometimes we have to do things we don't
want
to survive i'm trying to save the one
person left in my life
that matters to me
i can't help you what you talking about
is illegal
[Music]
and remember stay safe save and sanitize
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands he
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is real
and i'm gonna find it what you want when
i do just imagine the lives that could
be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked a legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they can smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon foyer
[Music]
good night
[Music]
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you the gift you always have
if there's an answer to your disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
i went from time i feel like more alive
than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
and then overpowering urge to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbid got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up doc
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking
no loud music even is shaking on a daily
basis
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
you